ton of leaked footage about Tucker
Carlson and it's obviously coming from
Fox I don't see who else could possibly
be leaking this footage and they're
they're doing a little drip drip drip
campaign to try to tarnish Tucker's
reputation in the wake of his
pseudo-firing I think he's still on the
fox payroll but they're just trying to
shut him up more on that in a second
so what have they got on Tucker let's
see what's the best stuff that the
people who want to take Tucker down have
on him
I don't want to be a slave to Fox Nation
which I don't think that many people
watch anyway
um we're gonna uh because I I you know
I'm like a representative of the
American Media now
speaking to an exile in Romania and
welcoming him back into the Brotherhood
of journalists
you don't have to talk is going to be
looking casual looks
is that okay
I mean this is airing on the nighttime
show and I wanted to look official I
don't want it to be like bro talk and I
and I
you know what I mean the majority of it
like if we go like 45 minutes it's gonna
be for Fox Nation but nobody's gonna
watch it on Fox Nation nobody watches
Fox Nation because the site sucks so I'd
really like to just put the dump the
whole thing so this this is supposed to
be the The Smoking Gun Tucker Carlson he
doesn't even believe in his own product
he's he's bashing his employers what
Tucker is doing here is what any good
media person would do which is he's
saying I have a responsibility to my
audience I want the products that we're
putting out to be better
every everyone around the daily wire has
said something like this at some point
including the founders and owners of the
daily wire has said something like this
at some point when we want to improve an
aspect of our product
no one obviously has ever said it about
my show because this show can't be
improved but the rest of the products at
the daily wire people will say look I
you know we have a responsibility to our
audience and this part of the website
isn't working that well and you got to
fix it up so that's oh about big Smoking
Gun okay what else do they have on
Tucker
yeah we'll do it live love that one that
one's my favorite one they said leaked
shocking footage from Tucker Tucker
Carlson is what making a joke
about a thing that Bill O'Reilly once
said in anger on the air
every one of these clips is just making
Tucker look better every one of these
makes him look more relatable he's he's
speaking very politely and comedically
with his staff and but then okay here's
the big one they're really excited about
this one
the the uh
the people who are leaking this have
found footage of Tucker according to
Media Matters acting really really
creepy here it is
you wouldn't okay I'm not you know what
I'm not qualified on that score I will
say
I thought his girlfriend was kind of
yummy
just kidding just kidding cases being
pulled off the bird
yeah the bird hey Media Matters for
America go yourself that's the
first thing I want to say tonight second
thing is totally kidding I don't even
know what his girlfriend looks like and
if I did I would not find her yummy
and if I did I would not find her yummy
that's a great bit
that's a great bit it's not there's
nothing creeping there's nothing
lecherous he's joking about this as if
it's on camera but okay the one that the
one that they're focusing on is they say
I've got proof Tucker's a racist and
it's because there's a text that Tucker
sent me says a couple of weeks ago I was
watching a video of people fighting on
the street in Washington a group of
trump guys surrounded an antifa kid and
started pounding the living out of
him it was three against one at least
jumping a guy like that is dishonorable
obviously it's not how white men fight
yet suddenly I found myself rooting for
the mob against the man hoping they'd
hit him harder kill him I really wanted
him to hurt the kid I could taste it
then somewhere deep in my brain an alarm
went off this isn't good for me I'm
becoming something I don't want to be
the antifa creep is a human being much
as I despise what he says and does much
as I'm sure I'd hate him personally if I
knew him I shouldn't load over his
suffering I should be bothered by it I
should remember that somewhere somebody
probably loves this kid and would be
crushed if he was killed if I don't care
about those things if I reduce people to
their politics how am I better than he
is
the the only takeaway I have from this
text is that Tucker Carlson is a much
more thoughtful human person than 99.9
of people in politics and media right
now go to cinch.com use promo code
Knowles
the weather is warming up here in
Nashville that means that everybody's
getting ready for their backyard
barbecues and campfires the last thing
that you need to be doing while getting
ready to host a barbecue is driving
around worrying about where to refill
your propane grill tank that is why you
need to check out cinch cinch is a
propane grill tank Home Delivery Service
they deliver propane grill tanks right
to your door cinch delivers on your
schedule requires no long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you don't have
to wait around at home track the order
on the Cinch app from anywhere whether
you are grilling steaks or lighting up
the patio heaters on a cold night
cinches propane delivery service ensures
that you have the fuel you need to make
the most of every moment go to cinch.com
or download the Cinch app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Knowles kwles cinch.com or download
the Cinch app and use promo code Knowles
to get your first tank exchange for this
10 bucks this is a limited time offer
you must live with an a cinched service
area to redeem It Go to cinch.com offer
for details Tucker Carlson is
recognizing
a a mimetic response that he has that we
all have watching social media which is
that we want to join the Mob We want to
join in a war of all against all and
just murder somebody that it excites our
anger and our envy and all the worst
aspects of our characters so much that
we want to do that and he became aware
of it and said this isn't good for me
every is this the best they've got
this is the best that it keep leaking
like this keep trying to destroy
Tucker's reputation like this you're
going to make him even more powerful
than he was when he was at Fox so what
are they going to try to do they're
going to try to sideline him for 2024.
according to reports according to the
Wall Street Journal also Tucker might
have 18 months left on his contract
which means that if they just continue
to pay him right now I think they're
paying him 1.6 million dollars a month
to do nothing to sit at home if they
just continue to pay him
he'll finish out his contract and then
after 2024 he gets to speak again
meaning Tucker is so dangerous to the
liberal establishment that they are
willing to pay him 20 million dollars
not to speak
what does that tell you about Tucker who
is a little more independent it's not
like he's some Fringe guy far from he's
extremely mainstream he's just a touch
more independent than other people in
the media
what does that tell you about Tucker
what does that tell you about everyone
else in the establishment TV news media
that they all get to have their shows
they all get to say what they like and
then Tucker steps out of line a little
bit much they'll pay him 20 million
bucks just to shut up before the
presidential election speaking of that
presidential election
we have got
one fewer
candidate in the race uh in 2024 at
least for this year a lot of people have
been waiting for Virginia governor Glenn
Younkin to declare and youngin says he
is not going to run
this year he was asked are you going to
be dusting off that fleece jacket and
getting out on the presidential campaign
Trail this year and Junkin says no I'm
going to be working in Virginia this
year
so then see this year what is it this
year mean the interviewer presses him
says so in the words of LBJ you will not
seek and if nominated you will not serve
and accept the Republican nomination for
president of the United States and what
does young can say he says we'll leave
that one to LBJ what I am very excited
about is that America seems to be paying
attention to what's going on in Virginia
which means he's leaving himself wiggle
room
but
for all intents and purposes he's out of
the race because even if he waited until
January 1st 2024 so we could say this
year I'm not running but next year maybe
I will if he started then barring some
Global event barring a comment coming
down and taking out Trump DeSantis
I don't know pens hey leave a vague Tim
Scott all of the candidates borrowing
that Junkin would come in at such a
disadvantage because he had not been
running for as long
this effectively ends this presidential
speculation which means some of the top
tier not Trump candidates
Cruz Pompeo Glenn young can now
they're out
they're choosing not to run
then you've got longer shot candidates
who are running and then according to
the polls you got one guy who continues
to lead the field and Lead it more
and more yeah I know tell me tell me
what you're thinking brilliant incisive
handsome I agree if you want to get more
of it you've got to ring that Bell ding
dong click the thing subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time
[Music]